- Do you like questioning
your intelligence?
Then do I have the thing for you.
- Riddle.
- Are you good at riddle
solving not drunk or at all?
- Riddles.
- I'm not, I can't really
think outside the box.
- I hate solving riddles sober.
- Me too.
- There's a box, I'm
over here for the riddle.
- Dead center.
(laughs)
- Who likes riddles?
- Dr. Seuss.
- No he likes rhymes.
- Bridge trolls?
- Okay, fine, bridge trolls.
- The sky?
(laughing)
That's really dumb.
- Do you know?
- No I'm sad.
- I already know what it is.
- Infinity, right?
- The universe, space, a circle?
- The end of time and space is.
- And surrounds every place.
- A border.
- No.
- 'Cause there is no end to time
and space, so it's infinite.
Why?
Because you're drunk.
(laughing)
- The sun.
- I gotta pee so badly.
- Say it.
- The letter e, yeah!
- Oh, I've heard this riddle before!
- I've never heard of it.
- How does it surround every place?
- Fuck riddles man!
(swoosh)
- Bitch, also infinity.
- There should be quotations around this.
- And that's why it's a fucking riddle.
It's not here to be your friend.
- It's an improper sentence.
I'm a man of logic, not a man of nonsense.
- Just 'cause I'm
smarter when I drink wine
doesn't make me a bad person.
- Riddle number two!
(laughs)
- Mouth.
- I'm drunk.
(laughs)
- I know what it is!
- Are you kidding me?
(laughing)
- Is it a river, or stream?
- To me it feels like a garbage truck.
The car is running, doesn't walk.
- Why are you so good at riddles?
- Dude I'm not good at a lot of
things, let me have one thing.
- It's a man.
(laughing)
- What runs?
- Diarrhea, your butt if you ate bad food.
- Okay that's all diarrhea.
- River bed!
- A river!
- We got that so fast we
don't have jokes about it.
You wanna just make fun of Kate,
'cause she's not figuring it out.
- I murmur, I don't talk, but it's like.
(grunting)
- [Both] The engine.
- I have a bed, bed of a truck.
I have a mouth, but I don't eat.
- They close down, right.
- Garbage truck.
- What is it?
- I'm right, fuck yeah!
- You got that pretty quick.
- We're crushing this.
- I believe you got one wrong.
I believe I'm crushing it.
- We're a team and this team is crushing.
- Riddles, hard but fun, if forced
to do them, I will rise to the occasion.
- And she sure enough did,
and I am proud of her.